[MUSIC PLAYING]
VIC IGLESIAS: Challenges
of multI-environment
infrastructure.
Let's just go through a
journey for a little bit--
talk about how we get
to multi-environment
infrastructure.
Well, first, you start
out with some devs.
They have a laptop.
They have some servers.
So you have two
environments, Dev and Prod.
You push code from your
laptop into your servers.
Everything's fine
for a little bit.
Then you add a bunch
more developers.
Things get a little hairy.
You start to add some tooling to
make this a little bit easier.
So you add some shared
Git repositories
to control your source code.
You add Jenkins because
you're no longer
SSHing from your laptop.
You let Jenkins do the
SSHing because you're smart.
And then, you add an
identity provider, right.
You need to manage identity
across all these folks
and have ways to control
what they have access to.
So we're getting a little
bit more complex here.
But we also added
another environment here
because we have a lot
of developers that are
trying to integrate their code.
So we added something between
development and production.
We added the
staging environment.
So we see these
logical environments
being built all maybe in the
same data center or cloud
provider.
Next, we start adding
even more developers.
We actually hired a security
officer, which is awesome.
They start to see a bunch
of our database credentials
in environment variables.
And they decided to
add some more tooling.
They added HashiCorp Vault
to manage our secrets
across our company.
Then, eventually, you decide
to move into a cloud provider--
maybe GCP.
How many folks are already
running on GCP here?
Yes, love you guys.
So you add more logical
environments, as well as you're
replicating staging
and prod, potentially,
but you're also adding an entire
different physical location,
right, a cloud providers region
on top of what you already had.
And you might start looking
at going from VMs to something
like containers.
How many folks are doing
containers or Kubernetes
in general?
Yes, a lot of you.
Welcome.
So what are some
of the challenges
that we see as we kind of
go through this journey?
Well, first, we're
deploying different ways
to different
environments, whether they
be logical or actual physical
different environments.
We see that our environments
like staging and prod
are starting to
drift a little bit.
They don't actually
look the same.
So we're seeing a lot more
things creep into production
that we didn't really
expect because we thought
staging was going to catch it.
We have trouble
managing access control.
There's different ways to
access different pieces.
So you start doing broader
and broader permissions sets.
And people can have
access to things
that they shouldn't have.
You also have
networking complexity.
Now, you have to
actually go and connect
to these multiple
physical environments,
maybe through VPN,
interconnects,
things like that.
Things get tough.
You have to manage
IP addresses now.
Finally, you have
built up a lot of tools
that maybe don't
work well together
or work well with the
infrastructure providers
that you've put in place.
So you have to start
integrating these things.
You can't just
throw it all away.
Sometimes you wish you could.
But it's been baked
into your organization.
So you need to start
thinking about how
to integrate these things.
So this is kind of the view that
we had in the last few slides.
We have a lot of
logical environments
and some physical environments
that we're thinking about.
What we want to do is build
a consistent platform out
of these.
So you ask yourself,
what is the platform?
Essentially, everything
except for what
the developer needs to do to
push code somewhere and get
it running.
You want them to be able
to have the same experience
whether you're in 60 different
environments or three
different environments.
They push code.
They monitor some sort
of deployment process.
And then, eventually, their
code gets out to customers
and starts providing value.
How many folks have seen
this gentleman before,
Kelsey Hightower?
Yeah.
Awesome.
There a tweet from Kelsey
for every single talk
I've ever done.
And this is the
one for this talk.
Kubernetes is a platform
for building platforms.
Right, it gives us
the starting point
to get an abstraction
across our environments.
And now, we're
talking about how we
can get there with Kubernetes.
So you'll have different
layers to your stack.
You'll have an infrastructure
layer where you have
disks, compute, networking.
You'll have a
platform layer where
you'll have these tools that
make it easy for developers
to get their code out into
those computers and networks
and so forth.
And then you have
your applications.
These are the things
that are actually
giving value to your customers.
And so here is kind of
that view of our old,
our previous diagram,
layered into these stacks.
So here we have Kubernetes
providing an abstraction
above infrastructure.
In GCP, that's our VPC networks,
our load balancers, our disks,
monitoring, logging--
all these things that
we have to, in the past,
use individually.
And you can also use these
across cloud providers,
and even On Prem.
And so then on top of that,
we use that Kubernetes API
to deploy our applications.
And you add tools like Jenkins
for CI and Spinnaker for CD.
You store your repositories
in Git, maybe GitLab or GitHub
Enterprise.
And then you provide
applications to your users.
So what are some of the
benefits of using Kubernetes
at that infrastructure layer?
Well, first, you get a
consistent deployment platform
that provides you a
single API or set of APIs
that you can use to manage
your workloads, right.
When you want to
deploy something,
you know how to deploy that
using an API or declarative
API.
And you get the same type
of deployment process
when you want to upgrade.
So a rolling update,
or a blue green,
you do that one way across
all of your environments.
Finally, this is available
because Kubernetes API
is available.
It's a managed service across
all of the cloud providers.
So you can instantiate
Kubernetes clusters
in each of them and even
instantiate them On Prem,
with GKE On Prem.
So now you have this
one workload API
that you can point your
deployment tools at
to build your platform.
So now, we've built
this platform.
We have this abstraction
for deploying to Kubernetes.
But one of the
things you'll notice,
as you start onboarding
to Kubernetes,
is you have YAML, and
YAML, and more YAML.
How many folks deal with
YAML on a daily basis?
Lots, lots of us, right.
This gets really
challenging over time.
There's a lot to think about.
There's a lot of APIs to know.
There's pretty good API
documentation out there.
But you need a strategy for
managing these manifests
across the environments.
So one way to do this--
sorry, to kind of sum up what
a Kubernetes application is,
or the deployable unit, it's
a lot of these different APIs
stitched together.
The pods are dependent
on a config map.
And volume the services
depend on pods.
And their labeled so forth.
And they're all defined as YAML.
So what do we really want to do?
We want to have some base
configuration that then we can
add and sprinkle in some
environment specific
configuration on top of-- keep
that minimal as possible--
create a deployable
manifest, and use
that to deploy our
clusters, whether that be
through kube control or
through Spinnaker or whatever.
This is kind of our end goal
with manifest management.
One way to do this is with Helm.
Do we have a lot of
Helm users in here?
Yeah.
So Helm can be seen
as a templating engine
for Kubernetes manifests.
It's got a really
large community.
And if you're
looking for examples
of what it looks like to manage
an application with Helm,
you can go to
hub.helm.sh and there
are over 500 applications
that are deployable today
into your Kubernetes clusters.
And you can see what the
patterns are within there.
It allows you to use
loops and conditionals
within your templates.
I'll say that this
can be challenging
as you are now in a touring
complete templating language
mode.
So as people add complexity
to your templates,
you're going to start to
lose visibility into what
each change actually does.
And I've experienced this
as a chart maintainer.
Sometimes I just have no
idea what a single line
change in a Helm chart
will do to a larger
kind of multi-file thousands
of line of YAML template.
The reason I first got
into Helm was because it
was really familiar for me.
I came from the world
of Chef and Ansible
and knew templating pretty well
and knew how to work with it.
So that's where I came from.
And it felt really familiar.
So it's a good place to
start for those folks.
Helm, if we go to that kind
of base, plus environment
specific config, plus
rendered manifest methodology,
that I mentioned
earlier, Helm allows
you to define a template.
And so you see those bracketed
values here on the left side.
I have my values dot image
and my values dot log level
templated into the YAML.
And then I provide
what I want those
values to be rendered into.
And then it spits
out a template,
a rendered template for me.
I can use the Helm template
command in order to do this,
and it just spits out the raw
Kubernetes manifest for me.
Another way to do this is
using a tool called Kustomize
And it takes a little
bit different approach.
It adds patches to
Kubernetes manifest.
So you bring a normal,
untemplated Kubernetes manifest
and then you apply patches to
that manifest on top of it.
It also can provide
tooling to add labels
across all of your
resources or add
a prefix to all your resources.
You might add staging to the
front of all of your staging
manifests, for example.
And it makes it really
easy to do that.
Another benefit of
Kustomize is that it's baked
into Kube Control as of 1.14.
So if you install
Kube Control 1.14
you already have
Kustomize available.
And taking a look at
the model for Kustomize,
you can see it on my
base, I don't really
have any templating in there.
I could apply this into a
regular Kubernetes cluster
and it would probably work.
And then I add my patches.
So here, what's
important to know
is that you have
to tell Kustomize
which thing you're patching.
So you'll see my patch in
the middle actually calls out
the pod, myapp-pod.
And the container that
I'm going to change.
And my change here is actually
changing the image from BusyBox
to busybox to busybox:dev
and does the same thing--
renders me out a template.
So on the right side here,
you see the Kustomization
configuration, and it's
called a Kustomization YAML.
And you can see I add some
common labels, a namespace
that I want applied to all the
resources, but the core of it
is I say, where's my base or
where are my base manifests?
And then which patches do I
want to apply on top of that?
Previously, you might have done
a Kube control apply dash F
in order to use Kustomize.
You have a Kustomization
YAML in your local directory.
Use Kube control apply dash
K in the local directory
and it will render and
apply the correct manifest.
The next thing I
wanted to do was
show kind of an example of
reusing as much of your code
as possible, or as
much of your YAML
as possible, across your
different environments.
So you can imagine a company
that is heavily Java based,
or has a lot of teams that are
doing a lot of things in Java.
So they create a base that
is how they would run Java.
This may include setting
some standard XMX
parameters, where logging
goes, some weird dash D flags--
I don't really do Java.
But you have a lot of stuff that
you bake into this Java base.
And then from there, you
have different Kustomizations
on top of that Java base that
create an application base.
And then from there,
that application base
can be Kustomized further
for each of the environments
that you're in.
So you're trying to
reuse as much as possible
as you go through,
so you really know
what the changes are going to
be as you work your way through.
So now that we have a bunch
of YAML that we could deploy,
we're next going to
bring on Ben Good, who's
going to tell us all about how
to actually deploy this really
good rendered manifest.
BEN GOOD: OK, so
before we get too far
down into how to deploy, let's
remember where we came from.
So back in day 164 or
whatever, Vic showed us
a picture kind of like this.
And we were using Spinnaker,
or Jenkins rather,
to deploy our code
out from our CI system
into our various environments.
And we probably added in
some Chef for some Ansibal,
or something like
that, to help us
keep our environment configs as
stable and similar as possible.
And then at some point, we
said, oh, this Kubernetes thing
is really cool.
So let's do some Kubernetes.
And at that point,
your CI pipeline
is pretty similar to what
your application pipeline was.
You're just changing from
building application binaries
to images.
But what's different now is
how you do those deployments.
So now you're
using shell scripts
to run kube control commands
to get your code out
to your various environments.
At some point, hopefully not
too far from that point, when
you're using shell scripts
to do those deployments,
you realize, I could
really use a tool
that's going to help me
see how my deployments are
going in a more Kubernetes aware
Kubernetes centric sort of way.
And that's where
Spinnaker comes in.
So in Spinnaker, you get
the benefit of Kubernetes
Awareness, as I like to say.
So you get visibility
into your replica sets--
information about how
your pods are performing--
if they're healthy or not.
In Spinnaker, your
Kubernetes clusters
are first class citizens.
They're just called
accounts in Spinnaker.
So Spinnaker knows
about those things.
And you can use
resource annotations
and then even do
automated rollbacks
to really manage your
deployment pipelines across all
of your environments.
So samples Spinnaker
pipeline might look
something kind of like this.
And it's going to vary
for everyone, depending
on the complexity of
your applications--
how many microservices
you might have.
But in general, what you're
going to do when you start
a deployment is to deploy
a canary, so a new version
of your application.
You're going to test
it, make sure it's
working the way you expect
it to from a feature
functionality
performance standpoint,
validate that thing,
and then roll it out
to production, or to
your staging environment,
whatever your
deployment target is.
The canary validation
could be a manual action,
where you say, looks good,
and you click a button.
At some point, that might
introduce too much latency
into the process.
So you might want to look
at a tool like Kayenta
to automate the analysis
of your canaries.
Some important
things to consider
when managing your pipelines.
So treat your pipelines as code.
I hope that if there's
one thing you take away
from the deployment
portion of this,
is that your pipelines
and your CI/CD processes
are really just code
when it comes down to it.
So if you're applying GitOps
principles to your application
code, do the same thing for
your application deployment
pipelines and build processes.
Try to leverage a tool
like Istio so that way
you can really understand
where your traffic is heading
and how much traffic
is hitting your canary
versus your running deployment.
And then, use the same
pipeline across all
of your environments.
So whatever you do for
production deployments,
should be the same kind of
processes used for staging, QA,
whatever pre-production
environments you might have.
Wrong direction.
OK, so in a single
cluster rollout--
we have our shared
tools cluster up there--
and you start your
rollout by going
to your staging environment,
deploying your canary.
And when it's validated,
you roll it out from there.
Same kind of thing for your
production environment.
So you deploy your canary, and
then roll it out from there.
On the other side of the slide
are some deployment strategies
that you could use.
But typically you find yourself
in the rollout scenario
because it's more
resource friendly.
OK, now, let's think
about this from
a multi-cluster perspective.
So because Kubernetes is
a cross platform tool,
you can be running GKE clusters,
you can be running GKE On Prem,
and you could be running
Kubernetes in some other cloud.
And that introduces several
complications to this scenario
here.
Notice in the slide, we
have two GKE clusters
that look pretty similar but
they're in different locations.
We have a GKE On Prem with a
different version of Kubernetes
and another cloud provider out
there with yet another version.
And you have to think about
how your application behaves
in those scenarios.
And then also about
how your interconnects
are happening there because
they can introduce variables
into the scenarios.
So again, with Spinnaker,
you can chain your rollouts,
your deployments, so you start
with a single cluster, deploy
your canary to that one cluster,
and that one looks good.
Then roll it out to the rest
of the fleet in that cluster.
And then move on
to the next one.
Maybe your monitoring
and your tooling
is sufficient that you can
do your canary roll out
to every cluster all
at the same time.
But understand that you're
looking at the results
from your canary
deployment in the context
of many other variables
at the same time.
So but the important part
is to canary on each one
because those
differences could have
an impact on your application.
And also to use the same
process for each cluster.
So once when you have your
application out there,
you also need to be thinking
about how to manage traffic
across those clusters.
So Istio is a good tool to
use for managing your intra
cluster with M1 cluster
or across your clusters,
or also known as your
east west traffic.
The other thing that's
really helpful to do
is to manage your
north south traffic.
So how much traffic you're
getting from the outside
to a particular
Kubernetes cluster.
And tools like
Cloudflare, or Akamai,
or Fastly, something
like that, can
help you manage that traffic.
And that allows you to cluster
to canary your application
at the cluster level.
So you could do this upgrade
that's shown on the slide
and know that that
new change isn't going
to impact your application.
So once when all those
things are in place,
you're in a pretty good
position to handle changes
to your environments and to
your Kubernetes clusters.
For example, GKE has this
awesome little upgrade button.
So when you upgrade, it goes out
and it rolls out the changes--
the new versions of Kubernetes
to all of your masters
and worker notes.
And that's awesome.
It's a great feature.
But that also introduced
changes in the API.
And if that does
cause a problem,
rolling back is hard in that
scenario, or it could be hard.
But having the ability to
control those, your traffic
flows, and what versions of your
applications are deployed where
is very useful.
Also like I
mentioned previously,
Kubernetes clusters are built
in and first class citizens
in Spinnaker.
So they plug right
in relatively nicely.
and Karl is going
to touch on this
in a little bit about some
of the nuances and challenges
there.
But they fit in pretty nicely.
And then also, don't forget
that shared cluster up there
with all of your Jenkins, and
your Spinnaker, your Vault,
whatever those shared
tools across your system.
Be sure to treat all
that stuff like codes,
keep it in source
control, and also try
to store your artifacts
from those processes
out somewhere else,
not on the cluster.
That keeps you out of
the pet cluster scenario
that we hope no one
finds themselves in.
And the Google
Cloud Storage plugin
is a pretty good way
to go about doing that.
So now, I'm going to
turn it over to Karl.
KARL ISENBERG: Thank you, I
am Karl, and I work at Cruise.
And Cruise is building
self-driving vehicles
to safely connect people
to the places, and things,
and experiences that
they care about.
So we're primarily building
a self-driving car fleet
in San Francisco right now.
And this is one of our open
source tools called World View.
It allows us to see
what the car sees
and be able to reproduce
its functionality.
So I work on the Paths team.
So I don't work
on the car itself,
mostly just on the
cloud backend stuff.
A lot of the stuff
that I deal with
has to do with the
multi-cloud infrastructure
that we have at Cruise.
We have hybrid, private cloud
internet, or network rather,
that spans on
premise GCP and AWS.
We have things On
Premise that need
to be On Premise like
ingestion from the car data.
We have stuff in GCP that
makes sense on GCP, like GPU,
and machine learning, and GKE.
We have stuff on AWS that
we've had on AWS for a while
and that makes sense on AWS
based on their strengths.
So this is just a
sampling of our sort
of multi-cloud infrastructure
and the variety of workloads
that we're running.
It's kind of wider than most
places that I've worked at.
So in order to make
this work on GCP,
which I'm going to
be focusing on today,
we ended up splitting up
our projects and our folders
in order to separate them
on environment lines.
We have environmental
folders at the top level
of the organization in GCP.
And then we also separate the
networks along those lines
as well to provide isolation
between development,
and staging, and production.
So if someone compromised
development on some CI
from open source
tooling or something,
they don't have access to
the production clusters
or their workloads there.
So it adds a little extra
security, a little reduction
of blast radius.
And what this
means is that we're
setting up multiple projects
per team at this point.
So for example, NetEng here
has a shared private network
spanning multiple environments.
And they share that network
with the other projects.
And we have different
teams that have,
for example, their
databases in SAS products
and other things like Cloud
SQL, other SAS products in GCE,
whether they're running
GCE nodes or GCP SAS.
And then the PaaS
team manages a set
of shared clusters across
the environment here.
So in order to make this
sort of multi-tenancy,
multi-environment workload
or spread work in GKE,
we also spread
these environments
across the GKE namespaces.
So we use GKE namespaces
for a tendency
that is not necessarily full
multi-tenancy, but also not
completely unisolated.
So we span these-- we
have these clusters
in these different environments,
and we have namespaces
allocated to different
teams across those clusters.
So a different team would
use continuous deployment,
for example, to migrate their
application from development
to staging to production, as
it increases in instability.
So a couple of security
challenges this presented to us
is that when you're not
using one Kubernetes
environment or one
GKE environment,
you have to figure out how to
make sure that your enterprise,
and your identity provider,
and your single sign on,
and your service accounts,
and your credential
rotation, and your
bootstrapping,
and your project works
across those clusters.
And effectively, what
that meant for us
is that we had to
go from managing
a whole bunch of clusters
to managing a smaller
set of clusters with having
a platform team that manages
those, so that we could
centralize that experience so
that we could level up the
experience that everybody had.
So there's some other security
concerns around encryption
that I'll get into in a
bit, but basically, you
need secret management,
and then secret injection,
and some kind of caching
for secret sometimes,
and you need to manage
TLS across your clusters.
If you have it in
more than one cluster,
it becomes a little
bit more of a headache
to manage externally.
So this is one of the
things you might not
think about when you start
going into multi-environment,
is that multi-environment really
probably means multiple GKE
clusters.
And when you're thinking
multiple GKE clusters,
you can't centralize
everything in the CRD level.
You can't centralize everything
in the Kubernetes layer.
It doesn't make sense to
store the source of truth
in one GKE secrets.
You probably want to externalize
those, and then replicate
those to your GKE clusters.
And then we have a whole bunch
of complications around access
control, around group
management, and role binding,
which I'll get into in a bit.
And then also like service
to service authentication,
access control is a
little challenging.
User to service, user to
platform, user through service.
All of these are things
that you might not
think of right up
front, but you'll
have to solve sooner or later.
So one of the things
I wanted to focus
on that sort of challenges
from the security perspective
is Vault infrastructure.
We chose Vault early on,
partly because we were already
using it, and partly because
we wanted to externalize,
like I was saying, the secret's
management outside of GKE.
We do like the GKE secrets,
but they're a little coupled
with names to base
permission boundaries,
and we wanted to bind
them externally to that.
So a couple of the solutions
that we targeted here
was a Vault log-in through
Kubernetes service account.
So you can use your service
account in Kubernetes
to log into Vault,
and that means
you have to authorize
that service
account with
permissions involved,
and that's managed externally.
And then also if you want to
go all the way into secrets
management here, you have to
get into either secret injection
or secret caching.
We went with secrets
injection, and that
meant using this model
on the left, which
is an init container that we
wrote, or you can write pretty
trivially, that basically
reads from Vault
logs in with the service
account, downloads
the secrets that are configured
in environment variable,
stores them in memory
volume so that they're not
written to disk, and then the
app container slurps them in.
So this is a little different
than environment variables
because you have to
read them from disk,
but it's not too
hard to read those
in from a bootstrap
or an entry point
in your Docker file
in your container.
So basically, this lets
us do lift and shift,
where we have a container
that doesn't know about Vault,
and then inject the
secrets into it.
But an alternative way is to
make your container of Vault
aware, and pull from
Vault at runtime.
That's also an
option, which we have
used in a couple of scenarios.
So GCP service accounts is
another integration in Vault
that we've enabled
and configured,
which allows us to log in from
the container with my Vault
credentials to ask Vault
for a GCP service account,
and then it asks it for
specific credentials that
are generated with a timeout.
So your application gets
credentials to talk to GCP to,
for example, talk to your
database in Cloud SQL,
or talk to your SQL in big
data, or something like that.
So we use the sort of
host of this solution,
and there's a couple other ones.
There's an AWS integration,
there's several other pieces,
and Vault is very powerful.
But what this ends up
meaning is that you
need to do a little bit of
Vault policy management.
So we ended up with a sort of
convention around Vault name
spacing that matches
our GKE namespaces,
which matches our
GCP projects, and it
means that your
applications are stored--
or the secrets that the
application use are stored
in Vault in a place
that is namespace aware,
that's environment aware,
and its application aware.
So what this allows you
to do is, for example,
have a team admin or
team members that go
and have permission to read,
and write, and delete secrets
on all the
environments, and then
you can have other people with
read permissions to those that
don't necessarily have
access to see them,
but you can just list them
to show that they exist.
And then you can
have the application
that only knows about
its environments
specific credentials, that way
you're not leaking credentials
across environments.
One of the nice things
that this provides us with
is it means that our
continuous deployment
solution doesn't need to know
about the application secrets.
It means the application
developer can update
the application secrets
independent of the life
cycle of the
application, and it means
that your continuous
deployment doesn't need
to be authorized with Vault.
So a couple of challenges
that we went to.
I'll just sort categorize
and bucket these.
Image building and
deployment is sort
of a problem we need
to solve everywhere,
and if you solve this in a
multi-tenant environment,
it's a little more complicated.
If you solve it in a
multi-environment scenario,
it's not necessarily
much different.
The way we went
with is having a GCR
that's central to the
PaaS team that hosts GCR.
But what that means is
that because the boundaries
for security are
around GCR, that
means everybody who has
access to push or delete to
that GCR also has permission
to delete other people's
containers that they've
pushed into that GCR, which
is a little bit of
a security risk.
So you can either
centralize this,
or you can spread it out,
delegate it to the teams
so that each team is
hosting their own.
But if you do that, then you
have to install a pole secret
on all of your containers--
sorry, on all of your clusters.
And if you're running
multiple clusters,
that can be a
little complicated.
So around application
operations,
some of the things that GKE
doesn't really provide you
with here have to be
solved, whether you're
in one environment or not.
That includes DNS configuration,
TLS configuration,
structured logging
will automatically
get converted by
stack drivers, but you
have to actually omit structured
logging from your application.
Using the right
metrics library is also
important for Stackdriver,
and in our case,
we use Datadog to omit
our logs to Datadog
because that's where
we were conventionally
aggregating all of our data.
And then around
lifecycle, this is
where we get back to
continuous integration
and continuous deployment.
The sort of templating and
cloud development environment,
we allow people to
develop locally,
but we find, in general, people
prefer developing in the cloud.
So they have more
resources available.
It's more like production.
They don't have to
have a beefy machine.
They can just do
it on their laptop.
So we provide a cloud
host and dev environment.
We host a staging
environment, which
we allow use for both near prod
deployment and load testing.
And then integration
can either be
spread across dev or
staging, depending
on where your CI is located.
With the use of Spinnaker,
you can get approval gates.
Blue/green isn't quite supported
yet, but deploy targets is.
And then account management
I'll get to it in a minute.
So one of the solutions you
can get to for image building
is to use Knative build.
We're not quite using this
yet, but we prototyped it.
And one of the things
we liked about it
is that unlike the
rest of Knative.
You don't need Istio to use
the build portion of Knative.
And so what that
means is that you
can get a CRD to push builds as
CRD Yammer files, and you can
do that from CI, and
it'll push the build
from permissions that Knative
build has into your GCR,
and that means we don't
actually have to give out GCR
push to any of our developers.
So what we've done
is we have a dev
GCR that anyone
can push through,
and then we have a
prod GCR that you
have to have a service
account to push to, or push
to from a build environment.
Another thing we did was
we've been using Spinnaker
for a while, and
one of the things
we realized that it was a
real pain to add new accounts.
So when we got to this
multi-environment, multi-tenant
system, and we had somewhere
between three and 20 clusters,
and then we decided, you
know, I don't want everyone
to have cluster admin to
deploy into whatever namespace
they want from Spinnaker.
We actually had to
isolate that down.
So now we're spitting
out Spinnaker accounts
by like 20 per
cluster, which meant
we needed a new
way to manage this
because each new account
requires a reboot of Spinnaker,
a redeploy because the admin
configuration is in JSON,
actually, under Halyard,
which manages Spinnaker.
So what we did was we
wrote a Spinnaker operator,
and the Spinnaker operator
basically just manages
your accounts, and manages the
lifecycle of Spinnaker itself.
So this is not yet
open source, but we're
leaning in that
direction, and we're
going to use it in production
for a little longer
to make sure we've
vetted it right,
and then we're going to
probably put it in open source
in the following months.
Some other networking
challenges we ran into--
DNS, I mentioned.
Public DNS turns out
to be pretty easy,
but when you start
doing private networking
or hybrid private
networking, you
get the word about private
zones, which is a brand new GCP
feature.
And then private DNS
from the cluster,
you have to start
worrying about if you're
going across
interconnects or VPNs,
you have to worry about
configuring the IP
mask on your cube
DNS or your core DNS,
depending on your config.
And this allows you to propagate
the IPs from multiple networks,
otherwise all you know
about is the GCP networks.
For Ingress, I'm
going to go over
a pretty complicated private
Ingress solution in the future,
or in the next slide.
And public Ingress, we mostly
just use GCLB, however,
you have to supply
your own TLS and DNS.
For Egress, public Egress--
private egress,
sorry, goes through--
if you have a
private network, it
goes through your VPN
or your interconnects.
You have to set up
your Cloud Router
to basically configure
IP propagation
across the clouds
in both directions,
which is a little
complicated, especially
if you start getting into
multiple networks per GCP,
and multiple clouds on prem, and
I'm glad we have a NetEng team.
So public Egress,
though we previously
deployed our own
nets with Terraform
because that was the
recommended solution on GCP,
there is now a Cloud NAT
solution that is beta--
I think it's GA.
And so we are switching
to that, but what it means
is you have to put network
tags per your regions
because if you are in the same
network with the Cloud NAT,
by default, all traffic
goes through that Cloud NAT.
And if you have two cloud
NATs in two different regions,
they start egressing across
regional lines, which is bad.
So you have to start setting
network tags on your nodes
to make sure they hit
the Egress traffic.
So this is just a few of
the little complications
that we ran into,
and hopefully, we
can avoid you from running into
them six months down the line.
So I talked about
private Ingress.
We have two of the three of the
pieces of the solution built
out, and have for a
while, and it works OK,
but we're not in love with it.
The GCE cloud provider, here,
this is built into Kubernetes,
and it knows about
GCP, and it configures
the IRB-- the internal
load balancer in GCP,
and that allows you to do, I
believe, TCP load balancing.
It's a layer four
TCP load balancing.
However, what we needed
was an analogy or something
analogous to our public
load balancer, which
does TLS termination.
So what we ended up doing
was putting Nginx controller
behind that.
So we have ILB routing that
Nginx, Nginx does termination,
and then we handle the
traffic internally,
and then we're
working on deploying
Istio to do the end-to-end
internal encryption.
But the last mile still exists.
You still have to handle
DNS, like I mentioned.
There's an external DNS project
that we have on our backlog
to look into.
It can configure the private
DNS or public DNS in GCP
for configuring
those, but it becomes
a little more complicated if
you have a private network.
For example, we've been using
route 53 for private DNS
resolution, and that
works great on AWS,
but in order to
get that into GCP,
we have to route
through the interconnect
to resolve all your DNS
connections, and that's a mess.
So we ended up caching
that on the GCP side,
and we're looking into a
more DNS mesh solution, where
we have some Google Cloud
parts and some AWS parts,
and they mesh together so that
they have multiple sources
of truth for the DNS.
So external DNS won't
solve all of that together,
but it will at least help you
provision your private DNS.
So the benefit of
this solution is
that all three of
those components
can be set together with
Kubernetes configurations.
So this is self-service
to the user.
The user can say I
want private DNS.
Sorry, I want private Ingress,
or I want public Ingress,
and I configure that the same
time I deploy my application.
Which means that I, as a PaaS
owner or a cluster operator,
don't need to care about how
people are doing Ingress.
I provide some solutions,
and they opt into them.
All these logs are
available to them,
and they can opt into
them with annotations.
It's pretty slick.
So we do have some operational
challenges as well.
When you are in
multiple clusters,
whether that's multiple
environments or multi-tenancy,
we have to figure
out whether you
want to aggregate or separate
your metrics and your logs.
So by default, GKE logs and
metrics go to the Stackdriver
in the same GCP project.
We didn't necessarily
like that very much.
So what that meant
is we had to give you
permission to all of the
users on our shared clusters.
And we didn't want to
give them rate permissions
because they were
our paths projects,
and they would step
on each other's toes.
So what that meant is
we had to sort of invent
a solution that
would emit metric
or, sorry, logs
to other projects.
So we have a Stackdriver
fluent solution
that will emit a duplicate
of the logs to the projects
that they own so that they can
do log to metric conversion,
and they can also
do log dashboards
or log metric dashboards.
For logging, we mostly
just use Stackdriver.
For tracing, we use
Datadog, like I mentioned.
For uptime checks,
we use Runscope.
So one of the
benefits of Runscope
is that unlike most
things like Pingdom
or other external
SaaS providers that
will do checks of
your applications,
Runscope allows you to deploy
an agent behind your firewall.
So we can do this in
the private network,
and it does a check
of your application.
So I'll talk a little bit more
about Runscope in a minute,
but about availability,
we also provide
a couple of features
of the paths
that don't come
native which GKE.
That includes backups
with Arc, which I believe,
has a new name that I forget.
We also do play a descheduler,
which makes things
evenly deploy across the cloud.
And like was
mentioned, node pool
can be upgraded with the
click of a button on GKE.
Unfortunately,
that only upgrades
the OS and the
Kubernetes version.
So if you want to change
the instance type,
or you want to
change node tags, you
have to do your own
recreation of the node pool.
So what we ended up
doing was terraforming
in a blue/green deployment
of node pools, which
is a little complicated, but
allows us to do zero downtime
deployments.
We have to have double
the quota we normally run,
which is kind of a
hazard, but it works.
So a little bit about Runscope.
We deploy the agents
on GCE and also on GKE.
We also wrote an operator
for this, which again, will
probably be open source soon.
And this operator takes,
currently, Ingress annotations.
So these Ingress
annotations tell
what endpoint do I want to
hit, what back end bucket do
I want to put them
in in Runscope,
and then Runscope
will tell the agent,
or rather the agent
asks the SaaS product
what should I check?
And then the agent
checks your applications.
Sometimes that's going
horizontally on the cluster.
out of the network,
and back in the Ingress path.
Sometimes it's going
between clusters, depending
what you're trying to check.
So this allows you to check your
applications from the full end
to end path, including Ingress,
and not just what Kubernetes
does, which is the cubelet on
the node checking your pod.
As you can imagine,
that doesn't really
cover much breadth
of networking,
and usually networking
is the problem.
So having something that
will do a sort of end
to end smoke test for you every
minute or every five minutes
is super valuable.
So we plugged this into our
local private networking,
and also a public networking,
and we have the optional.
We're going to be working
on converting this
to a CRD in the future so that
it's not five annotations,
but that will allow a little
more complicated configurations
of Runscope tests.
So the moral of the story here,
a bunch of these operators
that I've sort of displayed and
invented or worked with my team
to build has been about
putting your configuration
for your operations
of your application
where your application
devs can use it.
We have a DevOps
model at Cruise,
where every team that is
deploying or is building code
is deploying that code,
at least on the back end.
And so all of our
teams want to be
able to configure these
things about operations,
about logging, about
Ingress, about metrics.
Whether they know
it or not, they
need access to configure
these things self-service,
if possible.
So it creates less
operational overhead for us,
and it makes things
easier for them.
They can just go look
at the documentation,
and figure out how to do things.
And it makes it easier to do
your continuous deployment
because your continuous
deployment doesn't
need to be coupled with all
of these pieces that can
be independently configured.
This is the link to
our Cruise blog, where
you can see those open source
announcements in the future,
or see our previous
ones already.
And thank you for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]